dear brothers and sisters I again
salute all of you with the words of
peace peace and blessings go of God be
upon you
and the she is saying that this also was
the the greeting of she I thought that
was enough to
translate translate
again this was this was the greeting
of Jesus peace be as a matter of fact
this is the greeting of people of
paradise this a greeing of people of
paradise according to a statement from
our prophet
Sheikh mentioned a lot of good stuff
a lot of information that came from
him is really beneficial not only for
Muslims but also for non-muslims to cont
to contemplate up those
words and indeed the Quran is a book
that has a lot of information about the
life of Jesus as you heard different
verses and I'm not going to go in too
many of those those
verses I will try to start
from a
point beside beside the point that we
all have Jesus peace be upon him as a
prophet and the Christians also have him
as somebody who they trust and they
believe
in beside the theological point I'm I
want to move in
into a social connection or a social
bridge that can benefit both the
communities both religious communities
of Muslims and Christians and that
is focusing on what we have
similarities this would really can
make us move
forward before we talk about the
similarities I also want to emphasize on
the
point that our societies
nowadays
everywhere whether it is America or the
rest of the
world they need
believers they need Believers socie is
without
culture societies without
education societies without religion
these societies they cannot prosper and
the history
itself has
witnessed that those kind of societies
that they were lacking these
Necessities they always failed they
always had a doom
day therefore it's very important to
realize and recognize the fact that
societies who all religious
Societies in most of the cases are going
to be beneficial and fruitful societies
for their
communities nowadays we see in this
country that we live
in we love this country we are part of
this country the Sheikh who talked here
he was a refugee I was an immigrant
myself I came in America 15 16 years
ago
and since we live in this place we want
to see this place prosper
we
are we are concerned about the
security of this place we don't we are
concerned about the Improvement of this
place and we want to see better for our
children in the future as I said because
we are all part of this of this Society
even though we might have different
religions in different
Creeds but we need to find as I said
those points that are going to unite us
and make us go forward and as I said a
religious Society it is better than a
non-religious society as we can see
through the news
media
magazines
newspapers there
is there is an intention of many
different groups from the society and
elsewhere in the world to destroy the
religious principles
as we can see they Advocate to have
homosexuality everywhere in America and
elsewhere in the
world and it has become it has
become Society accepted thing the
society is accepting this it is saying
fine as long as it doesn't bother me it
is all good and they say as long as it
is society accepted it becomes a part of
the norm
here it becomes a part of the norm here
in in this in this place and this is
what we need to educate the
people we we do not we do not try to
fight with swords or to or go out there
and start shooting people or anything
that because this is against our
belief but we believe that it is very
important to educate these Generations
these new generations that that it is
not a normal thing to happen it is wrong
it is wrong for government it is wrong
for societies to make this thing
acceptable the Bible talks about this as
a sign of abomination that is something
that is wrong and it goes against the
human nature and also in our
God he flipped look at this he flipped
the nation of lot lot he flipped it
upside
down in the Quran there is a verse that
says do you see any remaining sign of
this nation do you see any remaining
sign so they were so much
humiliated there were so much disgrace
in the history of the humankind that we
cannot even find
the remains of these nations the Sodom
and gomorra we can't even find any
evidence because the Earth was flipped
upside down for these
people this is a sign for the humanity
to teach them and to tell them stay
straight stay straight don't deviate
from the
path I just mentioned to you a concern
which is a great concern in this place
where we live but also in the same
manner
many other Society diseases are being
spread the flu that goes from one
person to another one so fast that's how
these Society diseases are being spread
everywhere around the the world
especially in this
place and I want to remind everyone
tonight that there is
a state there is a word there's like
a Word of Wisdom in the Arabic language
that says what keeps Nation connected
together it is the morals are the morals
of that Nation keeping the healthy
morals good morals the moment these
morals are gone from this from that
society that Society is also destroyed
ruined together with those morals so the
morals the ethics are these things that
bind us together keep the it keeps the
strength of the societies every
everywhere in the world and there that's
where I come from brothers and sisters
to mention to you that Christians and
Muslims they have very similar morals
and ethics because as the shikh said we
believe in the same message that came
down to these Messengers Generations
after
Generations thousands and thousands of
years oh people believe in one God oh
people respect the elders oh people feed
the poor oh people spread the peace
around the world as a matter of fact I
want to mention to you a a verse that
our brother Muhammad was reciting in the
Arabic
language and peace Jesus these are the
words of Jesus by the way they do not
even exist in the Bible but we have it
in the Quran that Jesus one of the great
Miracles performed through God to a baby
that was just born Mary at that time she
was facing all of these people who were
pointing at her blaming her for having a
child without a proper relation and
saying how can you come up with such a
sin this and you're claiming
yourself to be a devouted lady how can
you do this
I want you to feel I want you to to
imagine and
feel how she felt at that time facing
all of these people blaming her while
she was a devouted righteous
lady and she had no other option she
could not do anything else she had no
words what to explain to them she ran
out of
words what did she
do she dealing with her fing
look at the baby let the baby
talk he said I am the servant of God
baby Jesus is speaking from the cradle I
am the servant of God he has given me
the book The Bible and he has decided
for me to be a messenger of God and he
has blessed me wherever I may be and he
has also made me a respectful child
towards my own
mother and he has also given me a
responsibility of performing The Prayer
a responsibility of observing the
fasting for as long as I might remain
alive and there we come to these words
peace be upon me the day when I was born
peace be upon me the day when I die and
peace peace be upon me the day when I'm
resurrected back again to life in the
Hereafter now if you think closely the
human needs peace throughout all of
these trans trans transitions in life if
you have no peace at the time when you
die how are you going to
die I heard people saying a lot of
people they don't even know how to
die even knowing how to die a person
must know how to submit to God when he
dies
millions of people don't even know how
to
die peace be upon me the day when I
die so he wants that peace of God
because he recognizes that peace is an
essential part of his being at the time
when he pass away and the time when I'm
resurrected when he sees the people
running around scattered everywhere
everybody preoccupied after their own
after their own a situation because
there going to be a day of hardship a
day where people are going to be
answering to God for the Deeds they have
performed in this life it's not a picnic
day it is not a fun day it is a day of
Trials it is a day of calamities however
for many Believers that day is going to
be a day of peace it's going to be a day
when they will be covered with the shade
of God and now Jesus Isa is asking
God and the day when I'm resurrected
back again alive I want that peace oh
God I want to be in peace that day as
well we don't recognize this anymore
we're far away from it we look for peace
in our money we look for peace in our
castles that we buildt we look for peace
based on our intellect our rationalities
without recognizing that this rality and
this money that we have in our hands is
just a gift and we are being tested for
these gifts how we treat them how we
utilize them we forget about this all of
us Muslims non-muslims Christians Jews
non-believers we all forget about these
principles but this is not what Jesus
was saying but beside Jesus we have the
example of prophet Muhammad this is what
connects look what connects
when the moment he entered the city of
Medina when he migrated we're talking
about migration right and refugees and
all that he himself was a
refugee he himself was a refugee because
he was Pro prosecuted by his own
people he had to leave his own town he
was crying when he left his own
town when he arrived in the city of
Medina when he arrived in the city of
Medina one of the man who was present
there he was saying how did you leave
the city of Mecca and he started
describing to him the trees the flowers
he started describing all the details
and he made him cry and he said enough
enough enough stop talking to me about
that because he felt this he was an
immigrant he was a refuge and the Sheik
is saying all of these other prophets
they are refugees they were refugees
they were migrants why because they had
to leave one place to another place to
go for the sake of God because they
found resistance at the place where they
were preaching their own faith so now
going back to Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him what did he say what were the
first words that he mentioned when he
entered upon his entrance in the city of
Medina he said oh you people he is
directing the words to the Christians of
that City to the Muslims of that City
and to the Jews of that City because
there were three major Jewish tribes in
that
City who were waiting for new Prophet to
come they were not they did not agree
later on however some of them became
Muslims but some of them they did not
agree because they were expecting to
have a prophet coming from their own
tribe they were expecting from a Jew man
to come and to be to be the messenger
however long story short first words
that are narrated by by a Jewish scholar
who became a Muslim as a matter of fact
the top leading Jewish scholar of that
time who became a Muslim later on he is
narrating these words mentioned by
Prophet Muhammad when he entered the
city of
Medina all you
people spread the
peace spread the peace first word you
make the connection between Jesus and
all the other prophets
God talks about John may peace be upon
him the day when he was born the day
when he when he dies the day when he's
resurrected Li so not only Jesus but all
these other prophets God is praying for
them now Prophet Muhammad is related you
see the relation the connection all you
people he
says spread the peace spread the peace
don't spread only peace with your words
by saying allum peace no no we don't
mean that spread the true peace let it
be out of your heart peace means that I
guarantee that for you there is no harm
from me I guarantee that there is no
harm from me to
you I guarantee that I'm going to be
very careful what I say on your behalf
I'm not going to harm you verbally I'm
not going to harm you physically
nowadays you see people everywhere in
the world trying to to start
fights people in
Iraq people in in Somalia people in
in Syria people in in Palestine in
Sudan and everywhere in the world
killings millions of people being killed
second world war millions of people
common system millions of people when
Lenin came in power when Stalin came in
power even even worse I come from a
country where thousands of people were
massacred you had Kosovo Bosnia a quar
million people in the 20th century at
the late 20th century
saan Mita another place in Kosovo 25,000
people massacres and the whole world is
witnessing these things with their own
eyes and those who have interest they're
going crazy after opening War worse
those who have their interest of money
they're killing people because they want
to sell their
weapons they're killing people the life
of the human has no value as long as my
pocket is full of
money as long as I can make
business and this is so shameful this is
very
shameful to kill people to Massacre
people to cause these Holocaust in the
20th and the 21st centuries just because
you want your interest to be fulfilled
you have an ego and also you want your
pockets to be filled it is so shameful
it is so shameful I don't know how these
people will be resurrected on the day of
judgment whether they are Muslims or
whether they're Christians or Jews or
non-believers whatever they are I don't
know how they're going to be in front of
God that day I don't know how they're
going to
answer but this is the word that we're
facing so he says
peace spread the peace guarantee the
people that from your from your mouth
and from your hand there is no harm and
this is what Islam is it is Islam is a
religion of submit submitting to to the
will of God through peaceful
manners and then he
said go ahead and feed the people here's
the religion in practice feed the
people don't talk to me too much show
that in action feed the
people and perform the prayer at night
while people are
asleep here we go a connection or is you
are in the service of the humans but
also at the same time time you are in
the service of your god of your Lord At
Night by performing the prayer when at
night when people are asleep that is a
highest level of
sincerity because nobody can see you at
that time nobody can see you but you're
waking up you are leaving the Sleep
which most of the people that have hard
time doing you're leaving that for the
sake of God to spend a couple minutes
with him to show him oh God I love you I
love you more than the sleep
so you stand up you perform a
prayer and this is out of the
sincerity as long as you do this you
will enter in Paradise it doesn't finish
there you will just enter Paradise no
you will enter Paradise
peacefully it starts with peace and also
this statement it ends with peace these
are the teachings the Divine teachings
of Jesus these are the Divine teachings
of Adam of Moses of Abraham of Isel of
Isaac and all of these Messengers who
were wrapped up who were
summarized with Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him our Islam is
not a religion of it's not a new
religion we don't believe that this is a
new message as the Sheikh said it is a
message that started with Adam with the
first human being and it kept going on
on and on and on and on until it ended
with Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him I say brothers and
sisters I
say that we should pay attention to
those things that unite us and work
together despite the fact that we have
different
theologies and I'll be very clear the
the main thing that separates us in
theology between the Christians and
Muslims it is that we believe that Jesus
is a messenger of God and we believe
that he was a Salvation for the
humanity because he came to cleanse
people's
sins but with what with the power of God
this is what we believe we do accept
that he was the one who was a Salvation
for this
humankind he came to purify people's
sins
we believe that and we do believe that
he is the awaited Messiah however we
believe that he was one of the most
honorable messengers of God who did not
commit sins he was pure of sins we
believe that too but so was the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so was
Abraham so was Noah and so was Moses
these five names that I just mentioned
right now these are considered in the
Quran to be
this is the the essence of the
prophets this is the essence of the
prophets these five
Messengers so we have a lot of Honor we
believe in them we love them any Muslim
who does not accept Jesus to be a
messenger of God and any Muslim who does
not love Jesus he is not even a Muslim
is automatically out of the Creed of
Islam therefore we have to recognize
these facts we have to appreciate those
points that unite us and work together
with the points that unite us and we all
are going to strive our best to spread
our faiths Muslims they try their best
in Mexico we have we just opened the
mosque in Sonora couple months ago in
her mosum they love it because our Dean
is not our faith is not a faith that is
misportrayed by media by CNN and fox and
all of their friends and folks no it is
a religion of Peace it is the statements
of prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that's what Islam is and
unfortunately those words they do not
come up on Fox because they have no
interest to hear these things they have
no interest they they pick up a man who
doesn't know much about Islam they put
him right there as a religious leader or
something that they hear the harsh
tone and they hear the extreme words
that are coming out of the mouth and
they Point finger they say this is the
representative of Islam this is what
Islam is bad away from Muslims
unfortunately it is our time I think it
is our time that we are being
misportrayed as in America it was
a time of Jews before a time of
Christians before a time of black people
before so I think it is our turn this
time but I hope that God is going to
make it easy inshallah and I hope
that we're going to work inshallah all
of us together in the future for the
prosperity of the communities that we
live in